hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so we
have an exciting video here talking
about the limits at infinity so this is
a symbol for infinity right keeps going
and ever never stops right so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna look at this
over here the limit as X approaches
infinity of 1 divided by X to the N
power as long as n is greater than 0
meaning positive what happens is this
whole thing is going to go to 0 ok and
I'll show you what I mean in some of
these examples okay it's very very
simple what we're gonna do is we're
gonna look at as as X gets larger and
larger what happens to this whole
quantity here so see if you can guess
you probably can guess as X gets larger
and larger what do you think happens
okay if you guess that it the whole
thing is gonna get smaller and smaller
you're right and the reason is is
because see how this denominators
highest degree term see the x squared
this is growing at a faster rate than
this numerators highest degree term okay
this is only X to the 1st this is x
squared so as X gets larger and larger
as it approaches infinity this is going
to outpace it's gonna grow at a much
faster rate this whole quantity is going
to get smaller smaller smaller it's
gonna approach 0 it's kind of like say
for example you know you're making
pizzas but more and more people keep
showing up at a faster and faster pace
then you can keep up with making the
pizzas eventually you're gonna have to
keep cutting those slices smaller and
smaller to feed everybody right so
that's kind of a funny example but the
other way to do this is you could pick a
number like say like 10 you put 10 in
here see what you get put a thousand in
for X and see what you get put a million
in for X and you're gonna see it's going
to get smaller and smaller okay now what
I'm showing you here is kind of an
intuitive way of doing the problem ok
but a more rigorous way of doing it is
look at whatever the highest degree term
is in this case is x squared right and
what we're going to do is going to
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by 1
/ øx squared okay anything divided by
itself is one so it's not going to
change the value of this fraction but
what we're gonna do is we're going to
distribute okay to the numerator
denominator and so look what we got we
get 2x divided by x squared plus three
divided by x squared all over x squared
divided by x squared plus four divided
by x squared okay now if we simplify
this further you can see one of these
X's cancels with one of these okay so we
have two over X plus three over x
squared okay and then x squared divided
by x squared is one and we have four
over x squared okay now keep in mind
we're doing the limit as X approaches
infinity but notice what happens so when
the numerator is a constant okay in the
denominator has a variable okay and it's
raised to a positive exponent like we
have here X to the first x squared x
squared as X gets larger and larger
because the numerator staying constant
is gonna get smaller and smaller it's
going to approach zero so I'm just going
to go like this I'm gonna say zero zero
zero so what we have is 0 divided by 1
zero divided by 1 is zero so the limit
of this whole quantity is just going to
be zero as X approaches infinity so
you're with me so far all right let's
take a look at another example let's
take the intuitive approach first
so this one what do you think the limit
is as X gets larger and larger so take a
second what do you think what do you
think happens there ok if you guessed
that it's 5/3 you're right ok and let's
see how he came about that see as X gets
larger and larger
does 7 change does four change no those
are constants they stay the same right
so what happens is if X is a thousand
you know you're just taking away 7 if X
is a million you're just taking away 7
so this term here is far outpacing this
constant the constant doesn't change
like that so we can essentially ignore
that because that's X is larger and
larger it's like if I told you I'm going
to give you a million dollars times 5
but then I said okay but
you have to give me back $7 see -7 you'd
say oh you know it's no big deal right
still approximately five million dollars
right okay so same thing here okay if I
give you three million dollars right
three times a million and then I say oh
I forgot to give you four more you'd say
oh don't worry about it because three
million three million four it's about
the same right so we're zeroing in on
this quantity right here notice that the
X's they're going to cancel one another
out so this is just going to be five
thirds so that's it okay now if you want
to do this in a more rigorous fashion
we're gonna do just like we did here
we're going to take the highest degree
power of ax which is X to the first and
we're going to multiply the numerator
and the denominators okay by one over x
okay so I'm gonna do the same thing to
the numerator and denominator because
this is like multiplying by one if I
distribute it to each of these terms
what do I get I get this would just be
five this is going to be 7 over X this
is going to be 3 and this is going to be
4 over X but just like we talked about
over here if you have a constant in the
numerator and X to a positive exponent
as X gets larger and larger this this
whole thing is going to go to well this
quantities gonna go to zero this client
is going to be zero and we're going to
be just left with 5 over 3 so the limit
is 5/3 okay now before we go further
you're probably thinking what happens if
we're going to negative infinity so
let's say instead of the limit as X
approaches positive infinity meaning as
we're going to the right on the graph we
go to the left on the graph you know all
the way to the left well still for this
one you're still going to get 5/3 okay
because you can see this was like these
are cancelling out right these are
insignificant right even if this was a
negative 1 million okay X is getting
really large negative now and this is a
negative a million you're gonna have
negative 5 million divided by a negative
3 million the two negatives are going to
cancel and you're still going to get
this ratio 5/3 okay so you're with me so
far let's look at one last example okay
this is like the third scenario here so
this one we had the denominators highest
power term okay is greater than the
numerators highest power term that went
to zero
when it was zero this one it was a tie
okay so even if I change this to like x
squared or X to the 20th okay like this
as long as those are growing at the same
rate they have the same exponent okay
the same highest powered terms those are
the same you're gonna get the ratio of
the coefficients in front of those
highest power terms now the third
scenario here is where the numerators
highest degree term okay that's this one
here is to a higher power than the
denominators highest powered term okay
so what that means is that this
numerator is growing at a much faster
rate than the denominator okay so this
is going to outpace the denominator so
as X gets larger and larger this is
going to go to infinity or negative
infinity and it depends on these terms
so again if you kind of follow along
with me just in an intuitive sense as
actually it's larger and large like say
X is 10 10 cubed is a thousand times six
is six thousand two times 10 is only 20
so six thousand minus 20 see this is not
having very much impact you know on
overall value of the numerator like this
term is so we can essentially as X gets
larger and larger we can ignore these
terms because you know they're not
adding very much influence okay so this
reduces down in essence 6x cubed - 3 x
squared and if we reduce it down even
further we get 2x C 6 divided by 3 and X
cubed divided by x squared so now you
can see as X approaches infinity this is
going to go to 2 times infinity right
it's gonna go up to infinity right like
that now if X is approaching negative
infinity you're going to the left on the
graph then this would go to negative
infinity okay now if I change this up a
little bit if I make this a negative
okay then this would be like negative 2x
as X goes gets larger and larger this
would actually go down down down towards
a negative infinity but if you're going
to negative infinity the two negatives
would cancel you would actually going up
towards positive infinity so in
conclusion let's just take a real quick
look at the three different cases the
first case the denominators highest
degree is greater
the numerators and that means it's going
to go to zero the second case it's a tie
between the highest power term in the
numerator and the denominator and you're
going to get the ratio of the
coefficients as X approaches infinity
and then the last case is where the
numerators highest degree term okay is
higher than the denominators highest
degree term and that's going to either
go to positive infinity or negative
infinity and the way you can tell that
is by looking at the two highest powered
terms in the numerator and denominator
like this one in this one and if you
look at the coefficients if they're both
positive it's gonna go to positive
infinity if they're both negative okay
it's also going to go to positive
Phinney because they cancel but if one's
positive ones negative then it'll go to
negative infinity
now if the limit is X is approaching
negative infinity okay then you'd have
to analyze it a little bit further so
like for this one it would be this
reduces down to two X okay so if X is
approaching negative infinity this is
gonna be negative infinity so you can
kind of look at those two highest degree
terms and then reduce it down and
analyze it from there so go ahead and
subscribe to the channel feel free to
send me a comment if you have any
suggestions or if you're enjoying these
videos I always enjoy seeing those
comments and I'll talk to you in the
next video